so the only difference between somebody
not my level is i have to
not come up at this height
i have to
go
lower without taking his hand lower that
doesn't make sense really because if i
go lower watch his hand high if i don't
go up and drop and i've done myself no
favors if i go out to the side
like this i thought hold that and then i
kept my body like this
not a lot
but i take my body just like that
this is a technical point saying where
my shoulder is i can't set myself but my
shoulder should be in line with his
wrist
if it's there
but here is it
what happens is when i'm going to take
him off so he's holding strong so when i
don't take them off i can't get him off
and what happens is this tip
here
what that does is when i go like that
it makes like a wedge
and this wedge
makes it slide upwards
come off
and you'll see just
that's wrong
often do this when i go look he's not
strong at all
all right on the center often say
i thought it was supposed to happen
if i do
this then i'm in my own way of my hand
if i do this
it's still holding
if i
move this
it comes out so what i'm doing is
uh mainly for allowance on this but for
everybody's ears
i'm saying
please go past
so one is
i'm in my own by my hand one is you go
around me if you want go past me he's
still holding me the other one is
and i
i adjusted this
so i'm really saying please don't pass
it
and that's why i love you though even
all the arts and that i've done
it's something
a little bit of movement
you're still you know you've still got
yourself
that's the same technique as in my right
door
but my whole belief is please go past
so
i give him the one
of clarity
this is too high because it would hit
this muscle
and i'd never get him off
so i as i go out to the side i go like
that and like
just a moment ago i actually do the same
thing
i'm sort of stretching it out look at
the front of the leg
now i drop the arm
softly
it comes off
okay
there it
i like this one because strength
strength will never
get off but strength will never get it
off
you just get tangled up
if they're taller than you it's easier
if they're smaller than you
you've got to
love
your posture
it should now be stuck
but
you should be stuck to me
i don't want to lose that
because i need it
just like get in there